people in Ecuador have voted against
drilling for oil in a protected part of
the Amazon it's home to tribes who've
chosen to live in isolation as well as
hundreds of species of birds reptiles
and fish a referendum and the issue has
been held alongside Sunday's
presidential elections 60 percent voted
yes to stopping the drilling it's a blow
to the outgoing Ecuadorian president
Guillermo lasso he says oil drilling is
crucial to the country's economy
well the drilling site is now going to
have to be closed down it's located in
the yasuni Nature Reserve in the Amazon
it's regarded as one of the most
important biodiverse parts of the planet
Ecuador's governments estimated that
stopping the drilling will mean a loss
of 16 billion dollars over 20 years the
operation accounts for 12 percent of
Ecuador's crude oil production of 480
000 barrels a day
our Latin America editor lithium and
Newman is joining us now from Quito
climate activists around the world are
saying this is very important what's
been happening
It's actually an extraordinary event
just remember that less than two weeks
ago the heads of state of all of the
countries that share the Amazon
rainforest that's eight countries of
South America were unable to agree on
not exploiting oil inside their
rainforest in fact there was a lot of
resistance to that the president of
Ecuador didn't even attend that Summit
in Berlin Brazil so what happened in
Ecuador is that the people themselves
basically grabbed the bull by the horns
and insisted upon protecting this very
very unique part of the rainforest the
yasuni national park and not only that
they also held a referendum on
preventing or or I'm sorry or
prohibiting mining in the area that's
just above where we are right now in the
choco region of the Andes Mountains well
in both cases the yes vote won the
referendum that was not expected
initially there was a lot of money used
by the campaign for those who wanted it
to continue saying that it was necessary
for the Ecuadorian economy but at the
end of the day sixty percent of the
people of Ecuador believes that
preserving this rainforest the
biodiversity and the people that live in
the rainforest was more important yeah
meanwhile as we were saying the battle
for the presidency of Ecuador's headed
for a runoff in mid-october voters are
going to choose between leftists
candidate Luisa Gonzalez and businessman
Daniel noboa
um Lucia just tell us more about what's
been happening and how we got here
hmm
well it's it couldn't be they couldn't
be more different right now we're
outside of a radio station here in Quito
where Luisa Gonzalez is making her first
shall we say uh interview or public
address since not winning in the first
round so even though she did win the
first round it was a disappointing
result she only scored about 34 percent
of the votes not enough uh to become the
president so therefore she's going into
the second round against a candidate
that was the biggest surprise of the
whole election Daniel navoa is a 35 year
old son of one of the country's richest
men he has very little political
experience but he managed to somehow
convince a lot of people in this country
especially young people that he is the
alternative that they need particularly
for providing jobs as well as security
which was the main theme Luisa Gonzalez
comes from a rather poor family she was
a single mother at the age of 15 and
then eventually went on to go to
university and become a lawyer and now a
presidential candidate while Daniel
Novoa comes from a very wealthy family
he's studied at Harvard he is a
businessman as you've already mentioned
so they they are different in every way
and politically as well because Luisa
Gonzalez's left wing she represents the
the citizens Revolution party of former
president Rafael Correa who did very
well for a period for this country and
then when the price of oil went down the
economy also plummeted and the
accusations of corruption and abuse of
power also soared he is now living in a
self-imposed Exile in Europe but uh he
is he is he still represents that party
and so Danielle Novoa is you could call
him a conservative but it's still not
very clear what exactly he represents
and who will be supporting him or not in
this runoff election it's a fascinating
time in Ecuador's politics Lucia Newman
our Latin America editor thank you very
much indeed